somebody I know like knows Charlie Kirk
and this is not somebody that I know
well like people listen to show they
still have no idea who I am
they've no idea why I'm not like a woke
social justice yeah that's crying ha ha
so they they think I'm like a
country-club Reaganite or something like
I could be be good charlie Kirk on the
show I said let me let me let me let me
I've had people on my show that have
credibly accused the Bush family of the
murder of President Kennedy profiting
from the drug trade human trafficking
the overthrow of democratically elected
government murder genocide really I will
go into that if Kirk comes on my show we
are talking Franklin scant I can say
Charlie what so the bit I'll give them
one question I'm like tell us about our
low taxes help the business climate
you'll get so excited and I'll be like
alright so now that we've gotten that
out of the way let's get down to
business
I got a few testimonies you might want
to hear and I just pull the book out
page four I'll have a copy for him
these people are clowns to clowns
they're saying whatever they have to say
to make money don't fall for it
don't be that stupid air just saying
they're actors they couldn't get into
Hollywood cuz your teeth are [__] up
core tasks fatigues [__] they're there
they're in another you know there's a
quote that says like politics is acting
for ugly people show business for ugly
people this is what it is did say
whatever they say they don't care Ann
Coulter during who is funny but mentally
unwell and funny she during the Iraq war
was like CIA's gray FBI's great we got
to go and invade their countries kill
their leaders convert them to
Christianity that was the quote that got
her fired from the National Review
now the FBI and CIA are horrible they're
all infested with globalist shills that
are trying to get rid of President Trump
we should build a wall and we don't
belong in any of these [__] countries
Syria whatever who cares if they're
gassing their own people let him do it's
not our problem she went 180 from all of
her views NATO
these people don't care about anything
they don't have any values their value
is relevance that's all they give a [__]
about am i near the bestseller list am I
on the top am I am I on the shows am I
on the right shows my on the sunday
shows imma getting invited to the right
cocktail party Vash it and they don't
believe in anything so don't [__]
come at me when I'm trying to get a
Pokeball tell me that I don't give a
[__] you [__] Psychopaths you nuts